JENNY: Hi.
I'm Jenny, and today
I'll be talking to you
about the top
security threats APIs
face as well as best practices
for how to secure your APIs.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
API security is a broad field
with many vulnerabilities,
threats, and
protection practices
to take into consideration.
APIs face the same threats
as software and web apps,
but because they have a
unique set of vulnerabilities,
they also face unique threats.
We've boiled all these down
to six main security threats
that you should
protect against--
basic software bugs, injection
threats, service availability
threats, user identity
threats, insider threats,
and spam and abuse.
The first API security threat
is your basic software bug.
Protecting against
basic software bugs
is a matter of organizing
regular tests and reviews,
and this is vital
to your success.
Start by ensuring
your organization
has good software
engineering in place.
This means using standardized
coding guidelines
and instituting code reviews.
Ensure that new code
is tested regularly
by reproducing security issues
in your own environment,
fixing them, and quickly
rolling them into production.
You haven't already,
implement security reviews.
Doing so ensures
that the security
issues that one API faces will
not be repeated or resurface
with another API.
You may also consider engaging
in 3rd party penetration tests
in order to get a realistic
picture of how vulnerable
your systems, data, and APIs
are from an outside perspective.
APIs also face
injection attack threats
like SQL injection, remote
code execution, or cross site
scripting.
Injection attacks occur
when malicious code
is injected into a
vulnerable software program.
Luckily, since APIs have open
API specifications or swagger
specs with well identified
inputs and outputs,
these threats are easy
to protect against using
consistent input validation.
API management
platforms like Apigee
provide a host of policies
that allow you to easily deploy
input validation.
Service availability threats
are also a large concern
to organizations.
These attacks target APIs
by flooding your network
with requests, resulting in
denial of service issues.
To protect against
these attacks,
we recommend that you use
the volumetric defense
tools Apigee provides, such
as rate limiting and quota
policies.
Using these with other
Google Cloud tools
like Google Frontend
Load Balancers, which
are built specifically to
deal with DDoS protection,
is a great best
practice to follow.
Although many people consider
good customer experience
as supporting and guiding a
customer through their purchase
journey, great
customer experience
also means protecting the
user and their identity
at every moment in time.
To protect against
user identity threats,
you'll want to use
an API gateway that
allows you to integrate OAuth,
JSON Web Tokens, signatures,
API keys, and more defense
mechanisms that validate
and ensure authentication
and authorization.
With API management,
you don't need
to sacrifice user
satisfaction for security.
Building and deploying
a developer portal
is a great way to give
your API consumers
a self-service
experience to understand
the APIs you're exposing and
request the access they need.
Plus, Apigee offers API
monitoring and analytics
dashboards so that you can gain
a holistic view of the health
and security of
your API programs.
Insider threats are
an increasing problem
for enterprise
security and remind us
that security breaches don't
just come from the outside in,
but can also come from within.
With so many employees and
contractors having access
to sensitive information
in an organization,
a key first step to defend
against insider threats
is to integrate
your API management
system and your
Google Cloud console
with your enterprise
single sign on system.
You also want to
centralize and structure
your change management
processes so that developers
have clear visibility
of any changes that
are occurring to your
software infrastructure.
This includes knowing who
is making the changes, what
the changes are,
who approved them,
and why the changes
are being made.
Last but not least, let's
talk about spam and abuse.
A considerable
amount of API traffic
comes from automated
actors that engage
in credential stuffing, brute
forcing, and content scraping.
The most important
thing to remember
is that you can't secure
your APIs against threats
that you can't see.
Establish API traffic visibility
through an API management
platform like
Apigee, where you'll
be able to observe
and capitalize
upon good, legitimate
traffic, while also
being able to identify and
block against bad actors.
In summary, APIs face
several security threats
ranging from basic software
bugs to spam and abuse.
API management is a key part
of your security architecture
and will help you spend
less time reacting
to security issues and
more time innovating.
Assessing opportunities
for improvement
and prioritizing
security efforts
based on perceived risks
is an important part
of doing business in today's
increasingly digital world,
and Google Cloud is here to
make your security defenses
intuitive, intelligent,
and reliable.
To learn more, please
review the resources below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]